[Música]
Bueno ya llegó el momento de hablar de
economía aquí en directo a América de
France 24 para ello contamos hoy con
nuestro compañero especializado Jorge
Hurtado Jorge bienvenido qué tal Rodrigo
todo bien muy bien ya aquí listo para
que me cuentes lo que está pasando en
Estados Unidos con el techo de la deuda
porque parece que hubo una paralización
de las conversaciones se han retomado En
qué punto estamos ahora Jorge de todo un
poco Ahí en esta negociación que ya
lleva varias semanas en Estados Unidos
el principal bloqueo de parte de los
republicanos es porque la Casa Blanca
pues no acepta estos recortes de los
gastos el Kevin es el máximo
representante republicano en el congreso
declaró a la prensa que su principal
negociadora abandonó las conversaciones
con funcionarios de la administración de
Joe biden los demócratas quieren
mantener el gasto en los niveles de este
año mientras que los republicanos
quieren volver a los niveles del 2022 un
plan aprobado recientemente por la
cámara del mes pasado recortaría el
gasto público en un ocho por ciento el
próximo año
también califican esta pausa que hubo
durante el día como parte de un teatro
porque según funcionarios de la Casa
Blanca estas fueron retomadas esta misma
noche el departamento del tesoro dijo
que el gobierno podría ser incapaz de
pagar todas sus facturas a partir del
primero de junio un posible impago
sacudiría la economía Mundial la última
vez que el país estuvo tan cerca de este
impago fue en 2011 también con un
presidente y un senado demócratas y una
cámara de representantes liderada Por
los republicanos o lo que sabe Jorge si
quizás solamente se habían ido a
almorzar para seguir probablemente que
son largas y van a ser todavía más
largas estas negociaciones vamos a
seguir en el país porque ha habido otra
noticia Que sacudió a los mercados fue
una declaración del presidente de la
reserva Federal de Estados Unidos Yellow
Powell que ha dicho bueno básicamente
dio una señal clarísima de que habría
Una pausa en la subida de los tipos de
interés Próximamente según Power las
secuelas de los recientes problemas del
sector bancario quitan presión al Banco
Central estadounidense para subir los
tipos de interés escuchemos parte de su
discurso
aunque los instrumentos de estabilidad
financiera contribuyeron a calmar la
situación del sector bancario su
evolución está contribuyendo a endurecer
las condiciones de crédito y es probable
que lastre del crecimiento económico la
contratación y la inflación así pues es
posible que nuestro tipo de interés
oficial no tenga que subir tanto Para
alcanzar nuestros objetivos por supuesto
el alcance de esto es muy incierto
Jorge mientras todo esto sucedía en
Estados Unidos en Japón se están
reuniendo los líderes del g7 Allí está
entre otros también Joe biden pero hoy
han dicho que hay nuevas sanciones para
Rusia en el marco de la guerra en
Ucrania y Es que desde Japón el grupo
sancionó a más de 300 personas empresas
también infraestructura que
supuestamente colabora con Rusia en esta
invasión a Ucrania las nuevas sanciones
golpean al sector energético de defensa
al minero y tecnológico de Rusia Estados
Unidos impondrá 300 nuevas sanciones
contra individuos entidades barcos y
aviones que están ayudando a Rusia a
contribuir o financiar de alguna forma
este conflicto Reino Unido anunció
también que prohibiera las exportaciones
de diamantes de Rusia y va a vetar las
importaciones de cobre aluminio níquel
de origen ruso esa industria es muy
poderosa en Rusia por ejemplo más de un
tercio de los diamantes que se extraen
en el mundo proceden de al Rosa una
empresa rusa de la que el gobierno de
Vladimir Putin posee una participación
mayoritaria el ceo de esta empresa
sergei ivanov pertenece incluso al
círculo íntimo de Vladimir Putin la
empresa extrae el 30% de los diamantes
que se sacan del subsuelo cada año en
todo el planeta y desde hace 6 años
colocó a Rusia como el primer productor
mundial superando a Box Juana la
industria de las exportaciones de
diamantes reportó a Rusia en el año 2021
unos 3.400 millones de euros para la
mayoría de los expertos los grandes
afectados por estas sanciones son los
ricos de Estados Unidos de Europa que ya
no podrían acceder tan fácilmente a este
lujoso mercado bueno interesantes estas
sanciones porque siempre hay que ver
quién financia Las Guerras Jorge ahí van
directo estas sanciones hacia Rusia
vamos a seguir en Asia porque ha
culminado la Cumbre china Asia central
bueno el líder chino prometió construir
conjuntamente fuentes de petróleo y
también de gas la Cumbre se realizó
mientras el presidente biden y otros
líderes del g7 se reunían en Japón el
esfuerzo asiático buscó desarrollar
redes comerciales y de seguridad
centradas principalmente en China sí
prometió aumentar el comercio
transfronterizo o desarrollar inclusive
autopistas y trenes al tiempo que animó
a las empresas chinas a establecer
almacenes en Asia central así como
acelerar la construcción de un gasoducto
adicional para suministrar gas a la
economía China y de esta forma también
promover incluso la energía nuclear el
comercio con los países de Asia central
alcanzó los 70.000 millones de dólares
en 2022 y el primer trimestre de este
año ese comercio entre China estos
países se aumentó un 22% y un punto
fuerte para china porque precisamente
los países del g7 están buscando
desligarse un poco del gigante asiático
vamos a cerrar con de Instagram no
perdón Twitter que podría tener un nuevo
rival bueno con ambos en realidad y es
que Instagram propiedad de meta estaría
planeando lanzar una aplicación de texto
para competir directamente con Twitter
persona familiarizadas aseguraron a
bloomberg que la versión Beta está
siendo probada por influencers y que
podría salir al aire en junio permitiría
también conectar cuentas de meta e
incluso con otras plataformas que ya
están asociadas a Twitter hasta ahora es
algo que Instagram no confirma pero la
compra de Twitter por parte del
controversial multimillonario alon musk
ha hecho que muchas personas abandonen
la plataforma creando un hueco en el
mercado que sin duda alguna otros
podrían aprovechar desde luego porque es
un mercado realmente grande seguro que
vamos a ver muchos cambios en los
próximos meses Jorge muchas gracias por
este repaso económico te invito a que
sigas con nosotros que ya viene una
semana en el mundo cargado de temas de
la semana